the ocean it covers three-quarters of  our planet it gives us the oxygen we  need it regulates our climate it feeds  us  the ocean gives us clean energy it  offers new medicines for millions it  provides a livelihood for millions more  it provides away  the ocean is owned by no one but shared  by everyone  Meyer I'm OCD le wada hyah - mule opium  me a pianist  Marisa Moyock Ian but the ocean is under  pressure  urgent action is needed  this October Global actors will meet in  Multan they know that protecting the  field means protecting our future now  the quick turn of the European Union  hosts the ala ocean conference together  we will commit to new action to protect  marine life to tackle marine litter to  use our ocean sustainably now more than  ever my ocean is our ocean  [Music]